Unless you’ve managed to make it this far
in life without setting foot in a store, you’re
probably aware that jello, popularly known
as jelly by my British compatriots, is a genericization
of the brand Jell-O which itself was derived
from the word “gelatin”.
(See: The Jiggly History of Jell-O) Gelatin
is a protein derived from collagen via a process
called hydrolysis, which breaks apart the
bonds of this protein with water.
While hydrolysis may sound complicated, it’s
simply a matter of boiling collagen rich animal
byproducts, usually bones, connective tissue
and skin, in water for many hours to break
it down.
The resulting broth is then carefully strained
before the water is evaporated, leaving behind
gelatin which can either be pressed into sheets
or sold as a powder.
Given that it is made from animal byproducts,
gelatin and products containing it aren’t
considered to be vegetarian and as a result,
there are several plant-based alternatives
such as Agar (derived from algae) and carrageenan
(derived from seaweed) available on the market.
(See: Why Seaweed is Sometimes Used in the
Making of Ice Cream)
Though commonly thought of as being modern,
gelatin based foodstuffs have existed since
at least around the 15th or 16th centuries.
Notably, in the late 17th century a Frenchman
called Denis Papin invented a device he dubbed,
“The Digester of Bones” (marketing genius
that one).
Papin’s original intention was to create
a device not too dissimilar from a modern
pressure cooker which utilized steam to boil
down bones either for thickening gravies or
creating a paste that could be readily consumed
by the poor.
Despite his noble intentions for the less
affluent among us, the device ended up being
too expensive for all but the wealthiest individuals
to afford.
In the end, the French (and eventually English)
elite became enthralled with the jellies it
produced, with one English observer noting:
“The hardest bones of beef and mutton were
made as soft as cheese, producing an incredible
quantity of gravy and for close of all, a
jelly made from the bones of beef, which makes
a good relish, the most delicious I have ever
tasted.”
The English are also credited with creating
one of the earliest known recipes containing
gelatin – a dish called “calf’s foot
jelly” – which was, unsurprisingly, made
from calf’s feet, though the feet of deer,
sheep or another similar animal could be substituted
if necessary.
The exact recipe states: “Take two calf’s
feet, and add to them one gallon of water;
boil down to one quart; strain, and when cold,
skim off the fat; add to this the white of
six or eight eggs well beaten, a pint of wine,
half a pound of loaf sugar, and the juice
of four lemons, and let them be well mixed.
Boil the whole for a few minutes, stirring
constantly, and then strain through a flannel.
This forms a very nutritious article of diet
for the sick, and for those recovering from
disease.
The wine may be omitted or added according
to choice.”
Originally designated as a food for “invalids”,
like many other gelatin-based foods, the dish
became something of a delicacy amongst the
upper classes.
Later, its supposed high nutritional value
saw various gelatin-based foods become popular
with soldiers during the Napoleonic wars.
So where do pineapples come into this and
why can’t you put them in jello?
Well, to begin with, it’s not true you can’t
put any pineapples in jello.
You just shouldn’t put unprocessed pineapples
in it, unless you like the jello to stay in
its liquid form.
You see, since gelatin is a protein, it is
very susceptible to breaking down into its
amino acid building blocks when it encounters
enzymes known as proteases.
As a result of this break down, the proteins
are unable to tangle together to create a
partially solid structure.
Bottom line, without this linking, the jello
never sets up.
In regards to pineapples, they contain bromelain
which itself contains sulfhydryl protease
enzymes.
As such, gelatin with unprocessed pineapple
added to it will not set.
However, since heating typically renders the
protease enzymes in bromelain inactive, canned
pineapple can be added to jello, as it is
heated sufficiently as part of the canning
process.
You might be wondering at this point if there
are any other common foodstuffs that similarly
prevent jello from setting?
Well, the short answer is yes- anything containing
protease enzymes is a no-no in your jello.
This includes several fruits such as papaya,
mango, guava, pawpaw and kiwi as well as figs
and ginger root.
In addition to this, protease enzymes are
also found in broccoli, mushrooms, spinach,
wheat and soy beans, none of which you’re
likely to add to jello, but hey, at least
now you know.
Finally, meat tenderizer, which is usually
made from either the aforementioned bromelain
or papain (derived from papayas) will, of
course, stop jello from setting.
As with the pineapple, however, if the food
items in question are first heated sufficiently
to inactivate the offending enzymes (in the
case of bromelain, heated to above 70°C or
158°F), they will then be fine to use in
your latest jello creation.
J-E-L-L-O, it’s alivvvve!
Well, actually, technically, jello is alive
– at least according to a 1974 experiment
performed by Dr. Adrian Upton.
Dr. Upton attached an EEG, electroencephalogram,
machine to a dome of lime green jello.
The jello produced alpha waves in much the
same way an awake and alive human would produce.
This experiment set the science world aflutter.
But what Dr. Upton was really trying to prove
is that an EEG should not be the only method
used to determine if a human is alive or not.
Since chemicals like bromelain break down
protein, they’re remarkably effective at
tenderizing meat and there’s “some”
evidence to support the idea that eating them
can aid in the digestion of protein.
Whether there is actually any positive effect
or not, pineapple and similar protease rich
fruits have become popular with bodybuilders
for
this reason.